So for step number five and six
orthogonalization, I'm going to create a new notebook before we
do step number five one second. I will import numpy.
And math just in case.
So the Matrix that we see in this picture.
Is Basis Matrix? So I'm gonna call this B.
and P dot array
of course, I'm using the NP array method so
I can.
Use nub pipe actually beats and methods.
It's
a vectors are 1 1 0 1 2 0
1 1 0.
1 2 0
0 1 2
and after orthog orthogonalization
will get
these three vectors
one two and three
so
I will call this now. Orthogonal matrices
are usually denoted with the uppercase letter q
What I'm just going to call this B.
orthogonal
so we have
one negative 1 over 2 1 over 2 and 0
so that's just negative 0.5.
0.5 and 0 and third one.
If you multiply the scalar value by these components will get
zero zero two.
zero
zero two
to make this orthod over you see here.
This component is two.
It is so this Vector is not normalized.
These could be normalized but
this is just by virtue of the operations, but
Let me show you how to normalize this.
Normalize this we must divide we must
find a magnitude of each factor.
And then divide each component or we
can divide in.
In vectors of matrices we can multiply it by one over the
norm.
Let me show you what I mean.
so
I will have N Sub 1 and sub 2 and sub 3
for these for each row.
so
Norm one will be equal to
NP dot linear algebra dot
nor of the first
Let's just say column. So let's imagine these are columns. They're
actually Rose, but let's imagine. These are colors. I'm gonna go be
zero
That's the norm of the first Factor.
If I want to normalize it, I'm going to go B.
And then multiply our multiplied by 1 over.
the norm
like so
I'll give me the new Vector 0.7 0.70.
so if I return here to this picture
That's 0.7.
Another way to express square root of 2, by the
way, in case you didn't catch this another way
to express square root of 2.
in math
So if you have square root of 2.
down here
That's just two raised to the power.
0.5.
That's what I'm doing in.
my laptop calculator
so the square root of 2 the square
root of 2.
2 over the to the power 0.5 over 2
0.7.
That's what they're trying to say here. These have been normalized. If
you see here what we do is we take the first Vector divided by
its magnitude.
And that's exactly what we've done here.
here
normalized
so then
if we create a new Matrix.
We orthonormal.
then
the First Column and B orthonormal
would be
this vector
So let me run this.
I cannot leave this up to you. Okay?
I'm just going to put three zeros in here
just as placeholders.
There's actually a method called zeros, but never mind that for now.
one vector
not only
okay.
So that's the First Column of The orthonormal Matrix.
I'll go ahead and do the same for
the others now just to simplify the code. I'm going to take this bit.
It's just remember.
This will normalize the first vector.
And make that the First Column of the orthonormal effect Matrix.
And I'm just going to copy paste this for the other matrices. This
will be one.
one
so
normalize the vectors of B and
Also, go no lines you can
see this picture for reference.
see
gram
Schmidt algorithm here
and then if I print p orthonormal
I want to let me reassign I guess I could do
this.
There we go. That's the that's the orthonormal Matrix now.
You see none of it's components.
exceed zero or go below zero
If we were to plot these vectors, they
would be orthogonal and they would have they would
not exceed a radius of one.
This is what an orthonormal Matrix is.
Now, let me show you how to do this using.
Numpy without you know manually doing
this calculation.
so
I will return here.
to show you how to or the normalize
ATA
Okay, so if you remember ATA.
Is that Matrix the orthogonalize it?
There is a method called. Let me see what
it was called.
It's called Earth. So I'm gonna go.
NP Lin algebra
dot horse
This is awesome normalized, I believe.
And I'm going to plug in.
Let's do 88 first.
Okay. There we go.
So that's how you order analyze using python.
That's the first that's so this is the Matrix. This is
the Matrix U, right? This is u,
I come back here.
That's the U Matrix.
Okay.
And then we have the Matrix.
That's step number six.
V
So if we
print you.
We print V.
So this one?
0.70
so we have the same Matrix up here.
and for s
For us we will we have up here. Right? We took we have
Sigma 1 and sigma 2
so for the Matrix as
that would be step.
Four step four we put into a matrix.
So step four.
We have a new Matrix called S and P dot
array.
which will be
let me just reorder these this Sigma.
So we have Sigma 1
and 0.
That's the first.
vector
the other vector
is zero
Sigma 2
Okay.
SUV
There's s there is U there is V.
We put these three vectors together.
So I'm going to go NP. This is Step. This
is no not this we've already done steps six at
this point.
But I'm just gonna multiply all three vectors.
I'm going to go math multiplicate now math multiple takes
two arguments at a time.
So I'm going to first add multiply the first two vectors.
that's
you and us so I'm gonna first multiply these
together.
So I will be.
You and this.
And then this will give us a new Matrix which
I'll multiply with v.
so NP Dot
matrix multiplication
this new Matrix with the
and if I come back here.
You can see we returned the
original Matrix 10 to 5 11.
ten two five eleven
Let me type this.
to get
the orthogonalized so the orthogonalized orthogonal
Matrix would be the Matrix.
This isn't correct. By the way, this is s
this is s
The Matrix U
is
The gram Schmidt algorithm applied to that.
And we would be the gramishment algorithm applied to this.
so you
will be the let me
type in text.
Ram Schmidt
algorithm applied to
ATA
and V is the same thing, but
the other way around
okay times a transpose.
Okay, just keep in mind that you do not apply the
grams with algorithm through just a on its own you have
to multiply you have to apply this algorithm to
the product of these two matrices. This is
the distinction at SVD.
Now finally if I bring you back to numpy.
We could have done this whole thing.
using
the SVD algorithm from numpy. So this would be SVD.
Let me call a manual for lack of better words.
but if you want to do this
There's a very nice method that does this whole thing in one go.
So I'm gonna have here SVD.
the SVD method from the pi
So this will be what NP? I think
Lin algebra.
Doctor SVD our plus and a
and this method will return.
What it is what is return values?
Three vectors us 3 in that
order, so I'm going to go.
you
s
V
If I print them all print you.
Let's try to be.
You see we have to say matrices.
This is V.
Like we have up here.
This is the this is the eigenvector. But what
you would do is you would take the values.
And put them in a square Matrix.
And of course, that's Matrix U.
Of course if you would multiply these together.
So if we were to perform this operation down here.
Oh, yeah, because this is
not as I need to fix. So yes see because
we can't just multiply this vector.
We need s to be a matrix. So we
need us to be a matrix.
Anyways, that's Matrix up here. It's exactly this one up
here.
this is really redundant but
What I'm saying is you'll get them same Matrix back.